good afternoon everyone and welcome to
another episode of the Friday app review
it's a beautiful sunny day here in
Mountain View so what else would good
android developer advocate to be doing
than sitting inside looking at apps my
name is reto Meier i'm joined today by
Fred Chung so we've got some apps we're
a little short of time so let's dig
right in okay awesome so let's see what
we will start with today is a swipe pad
so if we are switch to the part of the
phone we can see ya perfect we can see
the UI that comes up for swype pad now
what you can effectively do here is it
lets you create hot spots on your on
your phone which will then bring up sort
of this quick access menu so let's see
so I think here's in this UI you get to
choose which that's straight which
corner it is and it demonstrates it on
the screen so we've got the right edge
we can have the red shaded areas the hot
spot exactly exactly so that's what's
that's what's going to be activated and
then you can choose here to associate a
specific task with it so we'll have the
default pad for for that one see top
left corner make that recent tasks why
not need an add-on to proceed
interesting all right so I'm going to
skip yeah exactly ninety nine cents put
he had on well picked for head home so
let's skip say skip that for now we'll
go back in and so you've got basically
this just becomes a settings menu so you
can choose all the various things that
you're going to show up you can see
right away it's it's a nice-looking app
it's using the whole of the theming
you've got the tabs along the top as you
want so that all kind of makes sense
well I'll see what the actual app looks
like so as you can see there as I'm
swiping across home is that how did you
trigger the screen it was quite nice
around so I just click on the on the red
and drag up and at six it straight on
top she's a I'm not to be honest not
entirely sure how they pull that off but
it works quite well and so then I can
open up maps and
a shortcut straight to maps let's see if
we can and I didn't so you can launch it
from any where exactly so here i am in
maps so i just do the same thing oh wow
and it'll open music so i guess it
somehow overlays a window on top of
whatever you look it must do so i guess
similar to the way in ime works or
similar to lock screen of this looks
thanks it is it is it's actually it's
actually quite neat so I terms of
functionality I quite like I quite like
the app I don't I don't know that I
would keep it installed on my phone
because I tend to find that the sort of
the shortcuts to things kind of work
already pretty well I just have
everything on my home screen that I want
to be able to get to quickly but it's
it's definitely interesting an
interesting idea that's the thing with
android is androids other choice I guess
you may not like you but someone
somebody users out there sure precisely
so I like it and willing to blow yo does
it be known i stands for whatever
actions exactly i guess that's one of
the things i know people love to create
their own sort of home screen widgets
and have you know things like the
shortcut bar these sorts of things are
really popular so it's definitely a nap
with the market so yeah again if we if
we actually look at it in terms of
feedback you know it's it's a pretty
simple app so I'm going to ask trevor to
mute and monitor because that's going
excellent um yeah so it's it's fairly
straightforward i like the consistency
in the coloring i should sort of got
green fur for selected you've got sort
of these sensible tabs along the top you
know it all works pretty much the way i
would expect so no sort of strong sort
of comments on that side so you can
configure the different actions and the
different icons associated with each of
these grids exactly and if i if i select
on something which doesn't have anything
in there yet then it prompts me to say
you know what would you like to have
included which is nice if we have a look
at the phone again now you can see it's
sort of the UI for when you're doing the
selection again is it's it's simple and
pretty elegant you've got this kind of
cool you know circle around your finger
so that you can see what you select
it highlights things as we go over them
so in terms of usability I'd say that's
that's pretty good you got any comments
Fred yeah the only thing I like to that
is the bit of the red bar the hot spot
is that what they're calling it yes
about area I guess it will it
potentially interfere with certain
applications I mean it's pretty thin but
I'm just wondering if there are any
corner cases it's an interesting point
and I wondered about that particularly
in apps which have you know the ability
to side scroll left and right and our
games for that matter exactly and it's
it's not too bad from what I can tell
it's it's actually no it's not quite I
thought it might be detecting anything's
which came off the side but it's about
maybe three pixels share it intercepted
there yeah ocean right so yeah you're
right i guess you could test but yet it
is pretty sensitive and that it has to
be in that small zone i have found
myself more missing being unable to
launch it rather than getting in the way
of other things so yeah that's a good
point I think that's probably one of the
reasons why I would be a little bit
hesitant about using it it's just
because I worry that it's going to
interfere with my sort of normal
usability but yeah just work with a look
at work on the tablet abith version
excellent mr. Stewart Evan travel thank
you so and I just launched its
application it's got it walks me through
on the rough steps it was trading how
this app functions I am just going to
quickly click through the various tabs
that's a reasonable tutorial there yeah
yeah they wanna on a tablet screen it's
a lot of blank space bigger and tomatoes
earlier point you know there's a little
blank space on the left and right and
you might want to start adopting a a
screenshot for tablet because what we're
looking at is the screenshot for the
screen I mean for that a phone screen
that we just looked at that's a good
call and you could do that fairly
straightforwardly just by packaging
additional image assets for the larger
screen sizes right all right all right
let's go to next
and with more instructions no shortage
of instructions but yeah that's the job
up here hot spots general & addons where
I guess you can purchase some additional
items so now let's have a look at how
the hot spot is triggered so as I walk
my finger from the right-hand side of
the screen I popped up a bunch of grids
just like what we saw on the phone and
based on what we see here the it looks
like the grid layout is optimized for a
phone form factor with it was narrower
screen but it's sort of feels like the
grids squished together on a larger
tablet screen size but other than that
is pretty straightforward implementation
do you have anything to read no not
really it seems like the tablet is sort
of a natural follow on that though it
doesn't seem to have functionality which
is significantly different with the
exception of that of that great I think
you really want that grid to be kind of
full screen then again I get I guess
there's an argument to be said that you
want to be sort of within you know thumb
range or something right is it within a
thumb range hold this up almost white in
fact on your eyes up your hand oh look
at that perfect that's that's how far
across my thumb needs to go so if you've
got giant man hands then I guess it
works you've got dainty little hands
like me it's probably not ideal so maybe
you can rearrange the grits in this
region right let's go ahead and switch
to the tablet screen thanks Trevor yeah
I went doesn't suggest if you could
rearrange the great layout in this
region hmm right here yes normally
people carry their tablet devices either
on this corner or yeah 11 right or one
another and then depending on where you
like whichever side you dragged from I'm
you would just have the extra have all
the buttons there I like that that's
good that's good feedback yeah plus one
from return absolutely so rather than
sort of having it all cramped and across
on a tablet e to make a go full screen
if that's kind of the usability you're
going for all make it thumb usable yeah
that would be nice awesome good job yes
otherwise yeah it looks nice I really
like the you i really like a style
functionality seems solid as well so
yeah maybe change that sort of usability
on tablet a little bit try and optimize
that and I think you'll you'll have
something really nice so well done shall
we move on let's move on yeah I'm going
to skip the next one I've got on my
screen I'm going to go straight to a
beautiful battery so this is effectively
a widget so one of the interesting
things about widgets is what happens
when you start them from a from their
icon from the launcher icon so if we
have a look at the at the phone now you
should see what you get is he it is this
way to the phone working our producer
hard today okay so this is this is what
happens when you open it up and so this
is really interesting because the whole
notion of this widget is that it's
beautiful it's the most
attractive-looking widget that you could
come up with to display something which
you already have on the top left of your
screen so we can already see how much
battery we've got here at all times so
really the attractiveness is the key
feature most people will nice most
people are going to launch an app even
if they know it's a widget there's a
very good chance that they're going to
launch it first just to see what it does
what it says what it looks like and this
is the first screen that they see this
is not a beautiful screen green and
orange or an interesting color
combination I don't know that it really
works here as a placeholder for ad yes
ad goes here that's that's interesting
but bonus the buttons here exactly the
buttons themselves are kind of iphone
looking but kind of ugly iphone looking
you know if you're going to copy another
platform at least try and make it look
nice in this instance we've just gotten
rid of all of this custom styling and
gone just with a straight-up
normal-looking setting screen using
probably the the Preferences fragments
you know that framework so you've got
the gray blue hollow theming everything
kind of looks right I mean out of the
box if you do nothing look in few yes in
my opinion is also seems to be better
than
what we're looking at right now in this
instance absolutely I mean it's just you
know having the information here it's
kind of cool but yeah it's it's not it's
not it's not beautiful so yeah I'd go
right back to sort of the defaults here
I think you'll find that's a better
experience interesting go i wonder how
to put a type lithium iron you can
actually get most of this information
through the API so the voltage and
battery level you can get straight out
of the API type I think as well I think
if you ask for the battery temperature
is actually an answer yeah that's right
so the temperature sensor gives you
internal temperature in most cases i
think it's been deprecated now because
sometimes was ambience sometimes it was
internal and the api was ambiguous so
there's now an ambient temperature
sensor me you can use for that and
generally speaking the temperature
sensor is going to return the internal
battery temperature what happens to this
checkbox show battery state I wonder
what it does by place on chose to look
anything another thing itself let's
display battery info in status bar so
okay so it's done that up here so if we
drag that down again that's that's not
necessarily the most beautiful so again
this is a great example of where if
you're going to try and do something
which replaces the sort of default
functionality you need to bring
something extra to the table and a great
example here would be to make this more
attractive if you will click open this
up see status bar config the battery is
to be displayed okay so that's a little
bit grammatically suspect is the battery
is to be displayed in the status bar so
maybe work on that convert to Fahrenheit
so rather than saying can of currently
using Celsius scale using Fahrenheit
that's it hard of inverted so generally
if you have a look at the way that most
check boxes work in android like they
will just say what it is without being
extra verbiage so you would just have
Fahrenheit tick or not play our other
than sort of changing the text
right-hander or if you really want you
know do two radio buttons okay I get
clear that's that's true that's actually
not a bad idea just so that it's less
ambiguous oh yeah could be something
other than Celsius
fahrenheit in space Oh Kevin yeah move
exactly that's exactly what i was
thinking of you could be in kelvin let's
see so we've got themes which is always
nice so you can change the color that's
fine see I've got a menu I don't see an
option button of shame because it showed
up let me out exactly audience can see
menu button of shame it's not bad to
have a menu button but it is bad to have
a menu button which does nothing so just
switch your switch your target API yeah
and that will get rid of that or jump
back more more is always an interesting
button more from the same developer I
think yes okay so you probably want you
more button to be a little bit more
descriptive say what it is more of a
help okay so this is this is actually
what comes up the first time you run the
app if you're just going straight from
installation you get this help screen
first and so I would I think again to to
fred's earlier point this is pretty
quite busy you want to keep this as
simple as possible like it's it's great
to call out the translators and to you
know make those requests to get more
languages it's a great way to get more
distribution of your app this is
probably the wrong place for it if this
is what you're going to show people
straight away I think you know basically
just everything up that is probably all
you need to be displaying if you want to
display anything at all yeah even even
then I also got a small blurb explaining
what Android widgets are on top exactly
it's like assume this if someone has
installed this then they understand how
widgets work if they don't understand
which at this point your little blurb is
probably not going to explain it I do
understand the rationale behind having
it but perhaps less again less verbiage
it's all about making sure that users
get to the app as quickly as possible
and so you don't want to make them read
stuff because my eyes just glaze over
when I see as much writing or putting
more pictures what pictures like it's
just a rasa right absolutely and again
you know the this is kind of fundamental
to all of the advice for giving you hear
you know the key to this app is that
it's beautiful beautiful battery so you
want that experience for the users right
off the bat to be beautiful for them to
think wow this the person who put this
together really understand
do I they really know how to make
something beautiful at this point we're
already doubting that and we haven't
actually looked at the widget yet right
so it's not a look at the widget right
before going to 40 I like to give the
developer props of doing all the
translations mmm right please yeah
absolutely added oh but again i forgot
how to navigate that that's agree it's a
more no no it's help help thanks we go
so check this out so we go out about
what closer a dozen different languages
that's a good of it yeah Ukrainian
Estonian italiano outstanding so this is
this is any excellent stuff and you know
this idea of crowdsourcing your
translations I think it's a really good
one if you've got users who love your
app and in foreign countries you'll
often find that people are willing to
volunteer their time to provide
translations and particularly for apps
like this which probably don't have a
huge number of strings with the
exception of the stuff right yeah it
should be very lightweight and you would
think so yeah exactly my things yeah so
yeah good call I'm getting all the
translations and and well done all of
you guys for doing this yeah that's
really cool do we look at the widget
yeah let's look at the widgets do
alright so first thing I will point out
that the the icon in the app icon is
very attractive that's very nice we
scroll across so this is it this is what
it looks like um and it is I think
better say pretty beautiful it's it's
nice you kind of got that radioactive
glowy green situation here I can tell
you from experience that when the
battery level drops down below I think
about thirty percent it turns orange and
then bread under 20 so you know it's
kind of what you'd expect but does does
look nice but i think i'm sure by the
end of today's session will be able to
show you what it looks like it at a
lower let's check it out hell of a thing
though they are gradually transitions
from green through yellow orange and red
so one of the comments I wanted to make
so what I've actually got on screen here
are two different widgets so if i if i
go to add the widgets you can see that
there's two there's battery widget small
and battery widget and this is the
effect of dropping them both know which
one do you think is small
take a guess you gonna teach an eft
correct correct and so what it what it
actually is is the one on the left is
battery widget without padding and the
one on the right is battery widget with
padding so this is a two by one so it's
two cells hi and this is a one by one
yeah I'm so yeah so I imagine that
they've done this for being able to
position things on the home screen in
the right way I'd be interested to have
a better understanding of the the
rationale behind it well I was kind of
expecting for the big one was the
ability to resize it right it drag it
right I was expecting a big icon or
something something yeah so yeah I don't
think carefully about is certainly the
naming if you've named one small and one
not small then you would expect a size
difference now I realized that this is
probably all sort of PNG's or final
graphics which is why it looks quite
nice which makes resizing difficult but
again that would be an interesting thing
to try and do was to create a way that
it maybe you have multiple different
images different image levels and then
based on the size number of cells you
know load a bigger version so you still
have the high res but it's bigger
because yeah if someone really likes the
idea of beautiful battery widgets on the
home screen and they may want to have a
really big right a big one or one with a
different design yeah exactly different
designs are nice see I mean the same way
that you've got themes set up for the
notification you may want to do the same
sort of thing for the action or a
battery itself right you're different
different themes different kinds of
batteries car batteries you know
whatever else I wonder if they have
different graphics for the different
types of battery be hard to test back a
phone without a lithium-ion battery all
right let's look for that in view to be
when i hook this up to my car battery I
want to see a different image all right
shall we have all right at the tablet
version yeah la by all means yeah let's
switch to the tablet awesome try
beautiful and great animation by the way
so I've added a does the large widget
which s i currently have sixty-eight
percent basically we have the same
design
as what we just saw in the film this
then have a look at the app itself so
it's pretty trivial it's a stretched
version straight horizontal horizontally
stretched version of what we just saw
with the same set of information I'm not
going to repeat the comments on color
scheme and stuff like that arguably less
beautiful one really interesting thing
you can see really well here on the
display is that there's almost no
padding if we go back to the main sneak
keep pressing more you want more you
want to really bad ooh so you can
actually see on your screen here that
we've we're losing text because it's
being cropped slightly on out on our
output right so obviously it's not gonna
be cropped in a real device but there's
it's just right hard up against the
edges and you definitely want to have
some padding there just to give a little
bit of space yeah generally it's good
practice if you are putting a phone
optimized version to a tablet at least
do two things right increase the font
size and have some padding just like
what rate or suggested earlier well one
other thing as well I mean you do have
this beautiful imagery for the battery
widget itself why not stick that on the
screen I mean certainly a good idea it
may be a challenge on the phone version
but on the tablet man I'd make half of
my display just a giant version of of
the battery it may be in different
states something like that but just
something to give people an idea of what
it is that they're going to install the
thing about a widget is that it takes a
number of steps they have to you know
have to click several buttons and do are
several things to get it there the more
things people have to do the less likely
they are to do it so you want to take as
many you know give them as much
incentive as possible to go through that
process and install your widget let's
agree that here yeah as I was sitting
here I was waiting for the ad to show up
but it never arrived little play store
just start Oh disappoint okay and oh
they have a rate B button that brings
you to play store two for users to
provide them with some feedback okay
it's a good time they've got a good
indication there of some of the
different so yes I can oh we are
different states on the screen shot now
they actually this is confusing they
have right bigger
they have bigger bigger widgets how do
they do that how do you add the bigger
widget so I wonder if it's just because
the device that I'm around so that's an
ICS device over here right so that's
confusing so I have no idea how to make
the widget bigger it's not resizable as
per usual right yeah it's not the view
of definitely something odd going on
there so yeah it would be interesting to
find out from you guys how how do you
make the bigger widget of here and my
other suggestion would be given that you
can make it bigger is to just make it
resizable as you normally would right
well that's what this is a small one but
anyway that looks like a hangout for you
cool alright so we looked at beautiful
battery vehicle battery all right
perfect all right we're a cruising along
today I'll see we've got a few more to
look at I think I think I want to switch
22 airpush defender dare push detect a
push detect this is an interesting this
is an interesting app and this is one
which which which ian suggested we have
a look at today because he wanted us to
have strong words about something um so
if you have a look on the on the phone
you'll see what this app is is Wow
double us it's a lot of us with fancy
effects going on exactly exactly so the
idea behind this is that it's supposed
to detect basically apps and games which
use should we say controversial
techniques to try and encourage you to
monetize your app so all those sorts of
games i think in and down in particular
have have talked about these which will
basically create a notification even
while the app isn't running to push you
to buy so very bad exactly so i think
that's what air pushes i don't know for
certain but it's certainly the idea
behind this app is to try and help you
it's basically an ad blocker for those
sorts of monetization techniques so an
ad would show up in a notification in
the notification yes exactly I'm not too
sure about that exactly so I'm not a fan
of those so from that perspective this
is this is an interesting application so
it's basically like adblock for
if your browser but no specifically for
sort of questionable marketing at it got
it although from a technical standpoint
I wonder how to achieve it I'm curious
myself so I mean this is this sort of
fits into an interesting category
because it's it's sort of anti adware
and he you know sort of virus checking
sort of thing and generally we have
pretty short shrift for sort of
antivirus software because they're
pretty much all pointless and don't do
anything this one I don't have any of
these apps installed which would use
this so if I hit scan now it scans and
what what it's doing while it scans is
not clear to me hasn't found any adware
which is nice but again it's all right
on another no photo useful useful the
best full well indeed um I can almost I
have no idea whether it was useful or
not so yeah so it's it's interesting i'm
intrigued by the notion and certainly i
am a i'm not a fan of the of the sort of
techniques which this app is trying to
combat so on that level i think that's
that's fair enough we look at the app
itself from a UI perspective it's kind
of a nightmare you know half the screen
is dedicated to basically getting us to
to pay for the app which it does through
google play usually looking on a web
page from the 90s yes expecting
something that's blinking now yeah you
know and the thing about this so i can't
speak whether this app actually does
anything whether it's malicious serving
have no idea or whatever bubalus but
this is this is this is the interesting
thing i look at this and even
immediately my my spidey sense tingles I
think to myself this looks like a web
page that comes up in the background of
another web page saying you're infected
by a killer virus click here to download
the latest in green and what you like to
do the urn and android tether exactly
yeah you know you're one of the lucky
million it looks like a scam which like
i say i have no idea i haven't done
anything other than stored evolution to
the intuition exactly is look this looks
like a scam which is basically trying to
you know use my fear of another scam to
to basically give this person money so
you know from a presentation perspective
you are if you are doing something legit
you know show that you add value yes and
maybe describe how it is you do it
because you know certainly from from an
Android user perspective I'm like I
don't even think that it really can so
I'm really curious to know how it
suggests that it can do that and you
know you want to be as upfront as
possible over these sorts of things you
know to explain it all and sort of
focusing on the monetization is not a
great way of doing that like you know if
putting a user experience you're trying
to improve that user experience is sort
of a key behind the app then that should
be the focus and explaining that how it
works and why you should do it rather
than scan you scan your phone and also
please send us send us money it also has
a menu button of shame but that doesn't
really seem like the most important
thing right now yeah so I can this is
this is not my phone so I can it's real
time protection so presumably at this
point it's going to check for
notifications to see whether something
is being displayed by a dodgy as it pop
has anyone pop up a notification so I
know it doesn't okay which is okay so
this is a good point so it may seem
counterproductive for an app which is
designed to prevent more notifications
but given that this is presumably and on
well no this is interesting so it can't
be an ongoing source because for ongoing
service you need to have some sort of
notification so if you are going to be
doing so much actually scan something in
the background then you would need to
have an ongoing service and display that
it let's check it out does it even have
a service that's a good point settings
let's check out push push the SEC that's
correct all right let's check it out
doesn't look like it's running anything
all right anyway mm-hmm so yeah add to
it it's interesting so that's that's
that's my biggest criticism is that it
looks scammy and spammy even if it even
if it isn't and certainly if it is doing
something useful then yeah you need to
work on your UI I need to make it look a
lot more professional you know add the
padding use a update to the newest
target SDK so that you're you know you
get using the holo theme and all those
sorts of good things hope I'm not giving
advice to someone who's just ripping
people off that would be unfortunate oh
one sort of good thing about this F is
the icon looks actually decent well you
know you say that but can you read what
that says I can't I can't read it on its
own I take it back take about it could
be good but it's really small so I mean
what this indicates is it's a good
example of why what sir yes tablet a
tablet you can reasonably vegetable
airpush santosh to take yeah that's true
but it's a good example of why you
probably don't want to stick text onto
application high point because it can
get really small so that's probably it
something to avoid yeah Smoove on from
that people move on yeah we do this
let's even skip the tablet version
already yeah i'm guessing it's gonna
basically the same thing on s sign is
gone less bright there we go need to be
bright um okay so let's stab what we've
got I think a couple more minutes so
it's let's have a quick look at safe in
cloud all right let's do it it's the
last one which one serve you lightning
review that's right so I've already said
this one up so it wants my password move
that off camera look at that he tried to
get me not this time 503 ok all right ok
you can switch back now uh-huh so the
idea behind this is this basically a
password safe it
makes a bunch of promises as to a how
it's going to encrypt all of your data
and then basically lets you add
passwords the uido looks a lot more
modern on this yes affair with the last
one yeah so this this is this looks good
so the the look and feel of this app is
really nice it's all hollow themes we've
got traditional action bar we've got
navigation happening with the spinner
here which is exactly the right approach
we've got search built-in using the
appropriate search things add car dad
note all this stuff is exactly as you
would expect it to be including I think
settings if you go into settings you can
it's the sort of standard service of
vault for all of your passwords pens
whatever exact sensitive information
that you like to protect that's right so
you can go in here and have your gmail
account and stick that into this isn't
me home so they'd sure yeah I'm pretty
sure um so this is an example it
actually gives you a bunch of samples
built in which is a really interesting
way to do it so you don't end up with
sort of this empty screen when you start
up the app you start off straight away
spat on it with oh ok so these are the
sorts of things that I should be having
in there you know oh ok so yeah you put
your full details and all that sort of
stuff and then you can go through and
start the ones to know this is one
interesting thing in terms of usability
so starring these things is actually
modifying my UI so if I start I start
try to start last one that's sort of
disrupt low exactly suddenly like you
know if I go through the third one here
and then suddenly yeah where I moves to
the top and and you kind of lose your
way and if I just want I just want to
take the first three and then things are
just moving away so that's a very good
observation yeah I see what you see
where you're going with this and it
certainly makes sense to try and move
the favorites to the top for having a
sort of a dynamic uy like that is a
little bit confusing now I actually have
a really great solution for this because
usually I would suggest that you should
put it in in the navigation Dorrit items
yeah
but you know they've already they're
already using this for a sort of
categories so that trumpeting your
backpack on the table sorry mic pack
yeah no no Mike Oh getting a ton of it
appears no interference that's
unfortunate sorry everyone um you won't
have to put up with us for much longer
um so yeah what I would what I would
suggest is maybe if you change this into
a split action bar so that you have your
actions along the bottom then you could
probably have another another kind of
navigation along the top now that might
be something to look into because you
basically you want to be able to you
know have that have those stars
separately but without having them
pushed to the top yeah i'm not sure that
i have a great solution to that maybe
that's something that the Roman can can
suggest or even some of the people
watching if you want to make suggestions
into the G+ stream that would be
interesting but yeah for me that's a
little bit disconcerting having them
jump around like that the app itself is
nice and fast responsive everything else
do you have a quick look at Alinea on
the tablet yeah let's have a look at the
tablet so I think Fred's just starting
here so I just went through the setup so
well so it's a very nice UI with a
fragments on the left and one on the
right with a with an action bar
basically in terms of functionality is
the same as what we just saw they've got
a bunch of sample credit card and
password informations seated already
with e with yet when it comes in lets
try to have a look at the the behavior
when somebody tries to star something
started okay same behaviors interesting
popped to the top so maybe we can
potentially you know on the UI of a
tablet you can fit more items here
because that's just more in real estate
well in the in fact you're here on the
tablet they they're using the categories
are all listed here so they're not using
any top level navigation so you could
have that as a top-level tab between
naw start pretty easily if we switch
back to the tablet sorry to the phone I
just want to demonstrate at the
beginning it sort of gives you this this
intro telling you what the app does in
sort of a wizard and it goes through and
tells you exactly how your passwords
protected and all that sort of stuff
which i think is quite nice so it gives
you that on that intro I mean one of the
things I really like about this half a
minute again it's pretty straightforward
it's something which has been done a lot
of times it looks nice and I think one
of the keys for me is that as you're
going through it explains everything so
that once you sort of you read all of
this you get to the start you understand
what why are you doing things and what
is happening and then even giving you
the sample accounts it really helps to
push you so that you don't just end up
with something blank and empty in my
life okay what does this do how am I
supposed to use it that one suggestion I
have I don't know how do you go back to
the wizard screen one suggestion high
half is to maybe show so they use a
sense of progress because looking at
this screen I don't know how many more
screen is just gonna go right but you
know fortunately in this case it's three
but still it's good oh you can slice
through a swampy but in general it's a
good it's good practice to indicator
user ok how much more how many more
steps are needed that's really good call
and as well one thing which might be
quite nice so you have the three buttons
on the bottom or whatever so the
indicators when you get to the last one
you can't drag any further which is fair
it may be worth just changing the text
in your button at the bottom to done or
close yeah or complete act my contract
exactly we get get started just
something to indicate that okay the
Wizards done lets you know let's move on
to the next stage cool all right so i
think that takes us a little bit over
time we start a little bit late today so
thank you everyone for for tuning in
thank you very much to all of the apps
which nominated you soft for review we
saw some really nice ones today
apologies to the developers who we have
looked at in the past i have a big long
dock which has all the feedback that we
have for all the different apps which
I'm currently working through and we'll
send out to probably at the beginning of
next week and I keep saying that but for
reals you will definitely get you
back so in the meantime we've got in and
dan I think Dan's back this week it's
got a new hat you had a silent excellent
earlier so they'll be up next to go
through a bunch of games will be back
here at same time next week 1 p.m. which
is I think you TC minus 7 so yeah
looking at more apps and we'll have the
moderator page same as usual so if you
want to have your apps reviewed please
nominate there and we'll see you all
next week alright cool thanks guys
you